[Music]
but we are talking all things music
today with our friend frankie mourinho
from touring across the country to
releasing a new album to giving back to
the community he's really doing it all
frankie how are you i'm good how are you
doing good it's good to see you again
yeah you're back on the road you're busy
but we got to jump right to it tell me
about this new album it's something
really special for me so yeah so we i
mean we did when uh the last couple
years we've making a lot of music
recording a lot of music and um
the pandemic hit
all the live shows stopped so we really
started writing a lot
and just working on music and uh we just
put out this last album this was a
the end of like i don't know 12 albums
we've done in the last three years wow a
lot like too many and but this one is
called unknown artist
and um it's uh
a collection of songs that we wrote
quite a while ago and we just kind of
revamped them and and redid them and
it uh it just hit billboard charts at
number two on itunes it uh
it's doing really well for us so like
it's
yeah it's exciting congratulations on
that we always love when you put out new
music but we got to talk about this
record that you broke how many singles
did you put out
well we put out i don't know i think it
was like i think we did we did a single
every week and i think we did it for
like 80 weeks or something like that
and uh they all hit top ten
but um
yeah we had a we had a few number ones
in there too that was pretty good you
could say you can put it out there we're
talking about it 67 67 number one
singles
and uh that one whose record is it that
you you'd be at 60 right uh george
strait yeah george strait came at 60
madonna at 50.
here you are with 67.
well you know so far
all right well you're back on the road
you're touring and traveling everywhere
but you are performing at the smith
center next week i am i leave i leave
this weekend where we're doing a
symphony we're doing these symphony
shows again where my band plays and we
have like 100 piece orchestra behind us
yeah i'm doing that this weekend i fly
back in on monday and then tuesday we're
at the smith center well i've seen your
show a few times around here and you're
by the end of the show you are laying
down on the piano playing upside down
how the drinks are flowing that's just
because i get tired you gotta take a nap
on the piano but you're always so
entertaining everyone's always up on
their feet it's always a fun show is
that what people can expect at the smith
center yeah i mean it's weird the band
is super super great bunch of musicians
and just and just fun guys and the whole
point is like uh
you know we try to interact with the
crowd and uh it's just it's just a good
time you know more than more than
walking away saying oh i like that or i
like that i just i want everybody to
walk away going like i had a great time
yeah that's always how i feel i never
want the show to end so frankie thank
you so much for always entertaining us
congratulations on the records the new
albums just keep it going we love having
you here we'll see you at the smith
center next week